Hey do you like making learning English fun?
Then you will love our fluent with friends course.
In this forty eight week course you'll learn with the first two seasons of friends
using our methodology.
You will greatly improve your English comprehension vocabulary
and fluency and you can try it for free
right now all you have to do is sign up
for our three-part master class by
clicking up here or down in the
description below
Every single week we help learners like you understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost without missing the jokes
and without subtitles
just like Manonmani who said that he can't go to sleep without watching one of our lessons and
you can learn tons of vocabulary and
improve your comprehension too all you
have to do is hit that subscribe button
and the bell down below so you don't
miss a single one of our new lessons.
Hey music lover!
After you finished this lesson you might want to check out all of our lessons teaching you English with songs
in this playlist.
All right I hope you have a lot of fun
learning with one of the greatest bands
of all time and if you want to keep the
learning going then be sure to check out
one of these videos here and sign up for
that three-part master class I told you
about now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your English aww yeah